this tweet from billboard Chris who
responded to Elon Muskie said during the
inter during her interview with you she
was most excited about your initiative
to limit reach of tweets which are
deemed hateful freedom of speech not
freedom of reach in fact that was her
main selling point to the advertising
execs in the audience and she kept
coming back to it she went on to
chastise you twice for tweeting after
3am because people are concerned about
that sort of behavior what she also
wanted advertising execs to be part of
an influence Council within Twitter
she's not here to improve the user
experience she wants Twitter to be a
safe space she represents advertisers
and her natural inclination is to limit
speech and pan to those who push woke
ideology on the world you will have to
watch her like a hawk she was also
thrilled to spend 100 million dollars on
social justice initiatives at NBC and
forwarded government authoritarian
propaganda that the way back to a normal
life was to wear your mask no doubt
she'll bring in advertising Revenue in
the short term which is a long-term
mistake Elon responded and said I hear
your concerns but don't judge too early